Sí así es después de ese discurso que
ofreció en el Museo de Arte de Nueva
Orleans como decías con personalidades
del mundo de la cultura y en defensa de
lenguaje el lenguaje y la cultura
francesa se ha sabido y además esto no
estaba en esa agenda que se compartió
con los medios de comunicación que se ha
reunido también con el nuevo presidente
de la plataforma Twitter en lo más un
hombre que ha estado en todos los
titulares en estos últimos días el mismo
presidente Emmanuel macron ha compartido
parte de esta conversación a través de
su Twitter ha dicho que en un momento en
el que Europa en el que Francia Mira
hacia la descarbonización se ha reunido
con él lo más para crear pues políticas
fabricación de vehículos eléctricos y
baterías eléctricas también se ha podido
también hemos podido saber que han
estado hablando también sobre las
políticas de control por parte de la
plataforma para que cuadren para que
comulguen un poco digamos con las leyes
de Europa por ejemplo el refuerzo de la
moderación de contenido o sola o la
protección en la libertad de expresión
Así que desde luego un viaje mucho más
productivo de lo que se esperaba Amén y
qué resta en la agenda oficial del
mandatario francés en Estados Unidos
Sí una vez que termine ese encuentro en
el Museo de Arte de New Orleans el
presidente de Francia Manuel macron se
reunirá con su esposa la primera dama
Brigitte macron irán a cenar a uno de
los restaurantes más conocidos aquí en
la ciudad de New Orleans Allí se
reunirán también con personalidades
destacadas del mundo del cine y de la
música y a continuación se espera que el
presidente pase por french Man Street
que es una de las calles más famosas de
esta ciudad donde podrá disfrutar Pues
de la atracción turística más famosa de
este lugar que es la música en directo
sobre todo del jazz y por supuesto en
medio de una gran multitud de gente aquí
es muy interesante ver como todo el
mundo está pendiente de la visita del
presidente francés porque recordemos que
no pasaba por aquí un presidente francés
desde hace casi 50 años estaba previsto
que Manuel macron viniera a celebrarlos
el 300 aniversario de la ciudad de Nueva
Jersey en el 2018 pero no fue posible
Así que era una visita desde luego muy